where we happy the DA's here we are
continuing on from where we started
earlier this summer we had a attending
long summer on automatic course which
was very well received and that was also
a collaboration between PRM associate
I've had that we had summer course
Oxford there CCC so based on our
feedback we've expanded this to now and
this is a an orientation seminar which
will give you an idea of what what we
can expect over the next six months what
are these different modules we'll be
including and you will have a wheely
starting tomorrow based on this talk to
go ahead and register for this course
once again this time will be already
this is answering trapeze site licenses
for primarily undergraduate usage with
the area network institutions and ccpe
will spots for for people around the
list of people in at LSU and please take
the time the registration and give a
reason from why we think this was
reusable for you and then we will make
an assessment on the top yeah so first
of all I'm really happy that we continue
this it because during the summer we
only
and this time what we want to do in the
webinar is just go through exactly what
were the program cover how its
structured and then hopefully we'll get
to talk a little bit about what liz is
all produced so the first thing that I
want to point out is that you know this
is an attempt to kind of bring you
together several things that for all the
different so the program that we are
trying to experience something that work
for different levels of students faculty
you know different levels of students
people without any background in
mathematics really trying to bridge the
second thing I want to mention is that
this is the model that they're trying to
in a few different places not just here
hopefully a core piece of this program
is this bio informatics platform I'll
show you a little bit more about it
later but they here behind the platform
is really to provide a single interface
for people that are not familiar with
Cody don't
know how to work with beta databases and
things like that also not limiting you
to you know whatever laptop
computational power you have that's
really a centralized place and I'll
expand on that a little bit more on how
we use that to also track progress at
different time lines so the program
right now with this platform has several
different types of accounts that people
participating in this program will have
an education limits your ability to
upload large data sets but we will
provide uploaded so the idea is that you
you know again going back to that idea
of the project is that you have an
educational data set that is provided to
you long sighs I hope you understand
this is a biology you know how the data
was generated by was generated and all
of those things from applications then
you discussed an approach a possible
approach to analyzing data shows
processed the data for analysis
analyze it get some results and then
really we have an ability to just know
what we're expecting so we can check
whether but also we can do a discussion
around the resources what do they really
need and they do not have an ability to
you know kind of talk about what's up
and why would you choose other methods
so that process is
right so this is just one of the devices
instruments one where you see here one
is just an outline so more traditional
you have you know you have this now for
example you understand then you have
basically you have these are again
different types of the project from
publications that have either a specific
data type or some of them
[Music]
now August this is a big topic right you
need to understand college interesting
different and you need to understand the
treatments and what are they actually
doing and why do we need to write as
their challenge response so all of those
things are discussed on the modules
either under the project or in the
transfer Commons module and then you can
see that other data sets as alternatives
to that one really talk about similar
ideas new responses cancer so this is
really inspecting macrophages and the
Royal of macrophages in the development
of cancer how the immune system to
support the development of cancer versus
present
you have in the context of oncology and
the challenges around precision medicine
the challenges of precise selection how
do you actually use this so this is now
this is for each topic we will have an
orientation talking about you know what
a stretch comments what are we studying
essentially just a basic page then you
have four reactions talk about the
challenges that arise then you have some
time to write so all of these modules
provide you with
and then we have a workshop again and so
we know that this also provides you with
an opportunity to use value before this
let's say I didn't know a lot about
metagenomics I went through the course
and now when I need an extra talk about
this data I can really understand and
appreciate and the type of research that
he does so now that idea is to do
several things in the devil right so we
understand that some of you maybe
participated in to some workshops
some of them didn't we will try to give
a few laughs so you'll be
in this cheese expressions and Isaac
form expressions that would be under
comments then you have several events we
also single stone terms of topics so we
try and use this data set signal self
expression then over here you have gypsy
so it's the common really how does the
DNA how is it folded and how does that
affect you
[Music]
[Music]
you know Chris Taylor and a little bit
metagenomics not just but also
expression of these different icons
maybe not covered in depth but
Association studies what do you do with
these things right so a lot of these
methods are actually processing the raw
data but you have to do Jules somebody
generated before you what do you do with
them how do you get to so we have over
here a number of the MIT
they will be visualized and so on this
is right so how do you know which method
so the two things about that first of
all like I said in the beginning we will
be providing you with some standards
right so like you have and fast to file
do this and then once you do that and
you see them for this part
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so that is where we try to limit
those typical mistakes and so hopefully
cleans up some of those tips but except
for transcriptomics and here are a
couple of examples for genomics you have
three different methods to and then you
create a VCF file and in the VCF file
patients that were identified and you
can also you have manager
and you have the gypsy's pipeline so
where you see in these examples is
really that interface is going to say
doing things but at the end you will
always be able to throw back in a lot of
these methods you can identify them
[Music]
before is going to be either to
understanding how can you use these
methods to understand not just the
relationships between for example
samples but also why are they separated
rice with kind of features elections
using these methods so some of these
things we already covered in the summer
course but we are going to do a complete
review of what we did in the summer or
transcriptomics but also will have an
expanded course called machine learning
and that will be just about the mmmm so
whether it's usable but also what method
so really trying to understand data
types how to be different and what
methods make more sense we'll also talk
about building pipelines of machine
learning that's right I think that and
we're doing a course with Georgetown and
interacting with the areas to address so
the idea is that you have you combine so
again just to talk about the structure
of this program and the workshops and
the types of interaction so online
learning has a lot of implications right
you don't mind it's at the same time not
doing the things what we've learned from
doing these workshops here as well is
that people that don't take the time to
do the online stuff really slow down
right how many questions
we peel all of Elvis's so two things
about them one we did surveys 80% of
people think that even if the courses
online are the workshops workshops and
meetings to really try to work with
groups that are a little bit and also on
occasion but because I know that there
will be Iran institution sort of spread
out across the state you know we are not
and these are just some examples of what
we did we wanted to stress is that
bringing together information about how
and with the lessons is really helping
us a just pace and address the specific
challenges so just so that it's clear to
everybody this is the back end
everybody's activity is being analyzed
and we use it to address any challenges
but also to help individuals that want
to eventually do some actual piece of
the trade so things go wrong you know
why do they go wrong or you know people
that can't go through that and over you
can see is we create community
we track things like as well as we've
seen in the people that don't know what
happened you know and so we hope that
eventually some of you will continue to
do independent research utilizing the
infrastructure that
there's you see CT taking these things
further into getting actual results for
your application at the same time this
course is not going to be an opportunity
just for trying new projects right so we
did have a number of people that just
came back down made a census and said
this is what I want to do and kind of
ignored the rest so I know that that's
ultimately one fortunately physics worse
is not going to be that opportunity but
the other benefit I think about this
course is learning to read through the
papers without skipping the methodist
part and really understand Eliza you
know dealing with pre and post
assessments is we basically extracted
from there both the conceptual side of
things
so you know why were they doing this
research and the technical side what
methods that they use what were the
considerations and just measure the
results from the people that would
survey hoping that at the end of the day
you going through the courses working
through the data sets you are able to
understand what a figure like that means
and interpret in development I think one
of the limitations of this research
paper why is it important and how I
we started working on this and today
students and really trying for that for
that conference is an exciting
opportunity to really see what we've
achieved
that's works but I think also it's an
opportunity for people that want to
participate in decisions being aligned
with the conference and being aligned
with other activities that are happening
through and I think is an exciting
opportunity to showcase what so the idea
is that maybe all this takes place we
can have project ideas we can have an
understanding of you know how to collect
data for that next project and how to
plan for
or where can you find some online
resources that will help you at least
validates and also then you will help us
establish a way to you know start
addressing those challenges one thing
that I want to say about this first
pilot and we'll about those very
interviews that we realize that a major
limitation for them to get them in all
seven of their research data is are the
students and what we found was the
students that showed a lot of progress
during the course then easily found
mentors and collaborators to start
working on that certificate so if you're
a faculty you know bring your students
once they know what to do you'll be able
to help them use those skills along with
your resources if you're a student you
want to do a summary course with a
mentor and so I think ultimately those
are the types of results that we expect
especially in a community like this that
brings together faculty students and
students with different levels and
different right so we have students from
finance from computer science so really
really just one so that's that's an
exciting thing about now there is going
to be a week-long process for the
registration after this event and what I
think we just
is that we will post a schedule of the
different data types and different
programs that we will announce with just
about the registration itself maybe I
can ask John John and so by the time
tonic but I mean of course information
to send that right so 294 after this
meeting we are going to be talking with
Gus about the dates and how to align
those horses but pretty much what we
said is there's going to be an
introduction to it really talks about
how data has transformed so just
following on so I have a sign-in link
that
hang on I finally got the QR code you
can scan and there's a sign in this so
that would get your contact information
for those online please check in the
chat you make like five or that limit
but obviously Simon do you want to say a
few things my registration begins
tomorrow
another thing is these talks are also or
[Music]
try to get in we have people at the RN
reunited you to please encourage you to
stand faculty members to participate
okay so if you have if you want to
register today Jonathan if you want to
register online
I'm capable send in that suit so before
I kind of go on to show you a few of the
things that we've got that was really
really great is that we already have so
at the end of this idea and also we've
just another comment on how to use that
utilize that anybody else is a question
any comments
all right so just to demonstrate to you
a little bit practically so that it's
all clear this is the educational
platform we can already go over there
it's edu courses and preview some of the
courses a lot of them are freely
available so what makes this program
special and different from the freely
available courses is that you will
actually be loaded and the other thing
is that structure and around I think
it's you will notice that some of the
things here come with the price but as
it's part of this program a number of
specializations so that the projects and
the concepts align into some meaningful
direction you'll see the events the
different workshops are coming up and
then of course here are some examples of
the projects that we'll be using these
are just the same so during the course
we will actually do presentations now
here you will also see that you will
have a community and once you are
registered you will be able to view the
curriculum here and you will have a
forum and you'll see everybody's
progress
basically if in the second thing is the
platform just demonstrate a couple of
things so you'll be able to see that the
ratio of course again an educational
account has a Shinto the size of
people's you cannot know but in terms of
the raw like ask you file so as an
example we'll just take our next ticket
I'll show you how the system works you
will have this area on
more aggressive for example I want to
use with human data and period weeks
past you format then I'll be able to for
you as an innovation and then you will
have these SPL pilots which are really
links to so what you'll see now and it's
now we can start building so to build
your pipeline to start with processor to
start but then do you see that some
buttons or darker ears of a lighter so
the darker ones are they will actually
work for the data and so you know if I'm
doing our cleanup the raw data and
remove some of the adapters remove some
of those if you go back one step if you
see those doctor boxes as the light
boxes so is not determined by the
software will analyze your data and
accordingly maybe whatever
yeah and you will see that every step of
the way it changes you so known as the
data and then notice what output will
come
so you know if I want to use traumatic
in my research
then we want to clean up nightly UCR and
now that I've done that so once I select
both types of tea you can see that my
options are very different right so I'm
not going to go back and Alicia's
working for go back doesn't make any
sense and then I want to find my
expression you can also see that all of
these are organized into sections and
you can meet about the section so that
conceptually you understand why and
after you're done you can click on save
in the night so once I run the pipeline
I can go to my pipeline so I can't wait
to go back and see exactly what my
selections was and also and I can see
you when I open it in this pipeline you
can also see what was what was kind of
the celebration right so you won't see
it for those that are just this one
and then I will get a PDF report that
tells you how long the job took what
exactly and some figures and you can
work with the download section now
another question that the water column
comes up is how do I use this if I for
example and so what we've done in some
sections that are relevant is we
actually provide you with the source
code is it will actually exactly what
happened right so if you can just
breathe I mean I anything any of us just
just looking at this you will see so the
same well and you have to source file
and you have the cost right so the idea
is that once you learn how to navigate
to different sections you will be able
to decide what we wanted they want some
infrastructure or centralized now the
other thing that we will do is we will
talk about so for those of you that do
not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then we will have and then we'll
have our so because the supervised
methods that we have different things
like normalization visualization gene
set enrichment analysis so just useful
spreads that could we use process it
simpler to say that for those of you
that actually program or have experience
with programming or specific scripts
that you think are a must task for a
specific purpose or a section this
system allows you to incorporate those
scripts and so if you do have something
like that talk to me just to demonstrate
to do these are all the different
patterns so as you can see here image
analysis for example is consists of six
different
[Music]
we have so so we have
well you can send your questions by me
we hear you clearly all right so if you
have any business you can choose an
email and
[Music]
you